my brother did not trust me when I told
him he shouldn't eat the same amount of
Edibles that I eat
yeah I'll give you
one and if you don't heed that warning
I'm I'm in to watch whatever the [__]
happens yeah
he forgave me for those who don't know
the story though he texted
him the night and he just
and I said what is that he goes my Vital
Signs I'm freaking out
I go what he goes I'm at CVS in one of
those blood pressure machines I had to
come over here
tell them what you did after that though
oh dude what I did after that is I just
sent him a text I said dude you're gonna
be okay but whatever you do make sure
you don't and then I sent the text and
turned off my phone
I woke up to like 40 voice messages what
are you talking about